the eve of summer game fest is upon us
yet as we sit ready to bask in the sunny
glow of game trailers news and
announcements there is one former gaming
event giant that won't be part of the
festivities
e3 the electronic gaming expo which
began in 1995 sadly announced it was
canceling its 2022 event leaving us only
with our memories yet e3 has given us
numerous memorable moments and memes
from its two decades of history so today
we're shouting out some of our favorites
fair warning there are a lot of cringes
ahead
back in 2006 sony felt like leonardo
dicaprio in titanic
the playstation 2 had not only managed
to unseat the king of the gaming world
nintendo but also managed to hold off
microsoft's upstart xbox to become the
best-selling console of all time however
this domination perhaps led to some
overconfidence on the part of sony as
when it came time to announce the
console's successor sony chairman
kazurai took to the stage to announce
that the playstation 3 would cost an
astounding
599 dollars causing the room to
instantly fall silent the 20 gigabyte
playstation 3 will retail for
499 us dollars and 549 canadian dollars
and the 60 gigabyte playstation 3 for
599 us dollars
659 dollars canadian it's one of the
most shocking moments in e3 history made
even worse by the fact that microsoft's
xbox 360 was retailing at 399 dollars at
its most expensive tier in part leading
the 360 to dominate the early part of
that generation sales a lead that
playstation 3 would take years to
eventually surpass
[Music]
yet it's not just sony that fell victim
to overconfidence because in 2013 sony
got its revenge on microsoft earlier
that year microsoft had unveiled its
latest console the xbox one and its
reveal left gamers with a bad taste in
their mouth not only had the company
seemingly ignored its core audience of
gamers by focusing almost entirely on
the console's more multimedia
possibilities but its worst offense to
many was its aggressive drm policy that
would not only require the system to be
always online in order for people to
play games on it but would also allow
publishers to entirely kill sharing and
buying used games as a result microsoft
came to e3 with little public goodwill
behind them something sony took
advantage of during their press
conference sony released a hilarious
instructional video featuring execs adam
boyce and shuhei yoshida on how to share
games on their new playstation 4. this
is how you share your games on ps4
[Music]
thanks
please
it was an entirely simple yet knockout
punch that won sony the early momentum
in the latest gaming generations
mindshare
speaking of knockouts though keanu
reeves whether he's stopping a bus with
sandra bullock beating up fascist
computer elrond or avenging puppies with
endless violence we stand keanu reeves
here and that sentiment is clearly
shared by many gamers causing one of the
best moments at e3 2019 when keanu
reeves graced the stage during
microsoft's xbox event to reveal that he
would be appearing in cyberpunk 2077 as
johnny silverhand leading to this
beautiful exchange with an audience
member the feeling of of being there of
walking the streets of the future
is really going to be breathtaking
you're breathtaking
you're all breathtaking
all right all right all right so
not only do we agree about keanu's
breathtaking capabilities but this
adorable moment also proved exactly why
back in the early 2000s grand theft auto
was the king of gaming though
i guess that hasn't really changed
however the juggernaut gta franchise had
become synonymous with the playstation
with its initial exclusive releases for
gta 3 and vice city on the playstation 2
which made it all the more shocking when
xbox's peter moore took the stage in
2006 and rolled up his sleeve to reveal
his newest tattoo the grand theft auto
iv logo announcing that gta 4 was coming
to xbox and even had exclusive dlc but
it gets even better
microsoft and rockstar games have
entered into a strategic partnership to
provide exclusive
episodic content
via xbox live
sadly e3 moments are not always
remembered for how great they were
sometimes
they're remembered for being much much
worse
it's ridge racer
ridge racer in 2010 ubisoft was
seemingly riding high yet during the
middle of its press conference hosted by
community's own joel mchale it decided
to create one of the cringiest moments
in e3 history by having players run
around the crowd playing laser tag to
promote their then upcoming real world
shooter game battle tag it's attractive
people running around
um
[Music]
[Music]
it's deeply
deeply painful made even worse by the
fact that its e3 moment made more of an
impression than the game ever did
yet while ubisoft certainly has had
terrible moments at e3 it definitely
hasn't hit the lows of konami in 2010.
konami's entire press conference that
year was front to back one of the most
painful viewing experiences of our lives
and i can't even imagine what it must
have been like to be in the room i won't
put you through the hell of a beat by
beat discussion but some of the
highlights include live luchador
performers awkwardly interrupting one of
the publishers talking let's leave
now yeah
a group of karaoke singers performing
show tunes for glee karaoke revolution
and takifuji trying to get applause from
a deeply uncomfortable audience with
some of the worst lines in e3 history
hi
[Applause]
and also you'll see the that the
difficulty levels will be changed on a
two players mode and making
even harder
speaking of cringe though we'd be remiss
if we didn't let nintendo enter the
competition in 2008 during nintendo's
conference the iconic shigeru miyamoto
took to the stage to help promote the
latest game in the endlessly successful
wii games line this time wii music and
he and several others decided to play a
performance for the audience in the game
and
well
the music speaks for itself doesn't it
[Music]
perhaps this moment is why no one is
clambering for a wee music revival in
the same way we got a wii sports revival
for the switch well i'm here to say i'm
calling them out as cowards bring me wee
music switch
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
unfortunately wii music wasn't
miyamoto's only cringe e3 moment on this
list two years after the wii music
fiasco miyamoto once again stepped onto
the stage to promote the return of the
iconic zelda franchise with skyward
sword and like many games on the wii the
biggest overt change to the series
formula came with its addition of motion
controls promising to let you swing and
slash like link himself however when
miyamoto tried to show off how cool it
would be he ended up recreating a more
realistic portrayal of most players
experiences with the wii flailing about
as the controller refused to respond to
his inputs
and if i do a shield bash
then i can knock the rocks back at him
[Laughter]
there we go
thankfully years later skyward sword
made the motion control optional in its
switch re-release allowing people a
chance to re-experience the game without
worry of
wireless interference
alright we've been kind of harsh on
miyamoto but while he's certainly had
his awkward moments at e3 he's also
delivered one of its most heartwarming
and e3 2017 miyamoto appeared at
ubisoft's conference to discuss
nintendo's collaboration with the
company with the game mario plus rabbits
kingdom battle it's not every day that
one of gaming's biggest figures talks
about a game you helped create and
creative director david solani certainly
felt the profoundness of the moment
getting emotional as miyamoto discussed
the game
so when i met davide-san who is the
creative director of this game
yes
when i
when i met davideson i had just
just one condition for this project
[Applause]
it's one of the earnest and sweetest
moments in all of e3
but that's our list for some of the best
moments in e3 history but obviously
there are so many more from cliffy b's
gear's war announcement to whatever the
hell usher was doing here
so let us know what some of your
favorite moments from e3 were down in
the comments and if you're done
reminiscing don't forget to subscribe to
gamespot for all our impending summer
games fest coverage otherwise thanks for
watching
[Music]